I think the first we need to address is
this story from the Daily Mail yeah
Donald well I mean it's not from the
it's not necessarily about the daily
most about Trump he gave a speech went
to the Rose Garden Donald Trump says I
am your law and order president orders
heavily armed soldiers to DC and
threatens to deploy military nationwide
then has protesters tear gassed outside
White House so he can walk to a fire
damage church and brandish a Bible
that's quite the headline I love how the
media frames things wow that's a lot
okay going on there he had he had them
guest he did Trump was like I want all
these people to yes do it
I want to picture the church no no just
you know what you don't know who did it
I swear I can't stand about the media
it's gonna it's gonna come up every
single time we read stories like this
this this is like honestly it's not just
this it's everything everyone's now
posting this is Trump's America this is
what this America this is what you get
when you have Trump and it's like it's
all the Democrat states they're the ones
they're the ones who let out all the
criminals like a month ago right from Co
vid and we're you know arresting regular
you know people for walking around it's
like what is going on and then don't
hang their bail like how is I didn't how
is it on Trump I don't get it exactly
it's well so so really kinda put pin in
that yeah well we're gonna come back to
each those points as we age goodness
yeah take a look at take a look at this
right yeah yeah they say then has
protesters to your gas that's at the
White House so he can walk to a fire
damage Church in Greenwich a Bible that
is called framing my friends yeah Wow
how about I frame that for you in a
beneficial light Donald Trump you know
let's see orders soldiers to defend
Washington DC from violent riots defends
local residents and surveys the damage
on a church to assure Americans at the
church still stands
historical to framing framing how about
we tell you what actually happened
protesters in fort of the white house
were dispersed with tear gas and police
Donald Trump took a photograph and
checked out the church it isn't gonna be
positive or negative you just tell them
what happened if you want to frame it
beneficially or otherwise but let's be
fair man
Donald Trump had to go to the church
okay this is this is ridiculous BuzzFeed
writes the same thing do I have this
from I think I have this thing from was
reframing where there's a peaceful
protesters were gassed goodness outside
the White House so Trump could get a
photo-op it
Church where there's no way I mean for
the most part outside I think so but
when they're ordered to dispersed and
they wouldn't you could argue they were
no longer peaceful yeah I mean like the
cops were like move back move back and
then they didn't and then tear gas been
flying but that's not the the issue for
me the issue for me is that st. John's
Church was set on fire by these rioters
and people were freaking out regular so
st. John's Church isn't just a church
for Christians it is an American
National Monument it is a historical
site it is is like that's like stamped
boom on the front yeah is where all the
presents I think accept Nixon or not all
him because it was built in like 1807 or
something but all presidents pray there
Trump is going there in my opinion and
again just my opinion because the
American people are probably scared what
happened to our church this is the
president's church across from the White
House
so Trump went there took a picture in
front of it why that picture shows
America that the church still stands
that a National Monument monument was
not destroyed despite all the reports
you saw yesterday about it being up in
flames Fox News went in there you could
see the flames billowing up and they put
the fire out and now Trump is standing
there showing he's in control the church
is fine and there it is yeah
the media's want to tell you that though
media wants to tell you that he's just
gassing people for no reason
everything's wrong everything's his
fault well let's let's talk about that
let's put let's pull the pin out of what
you just mentioned yeah well I mean I
got to say I tweet and I I you know
because you guys are constantly giving
me stories I I asked this weekend I'm
like where do we go from here and you
know what do you think of Trump labeling
and Tifa terrorists and I'm getting all
all different sides of this story you
know I'm seeing it from many different
people and one thing I've noticed is
there's a lot of people blaming trunk
with no substance I'm seeing a lot of
things that don't really make sense you
know the whole Obama gate all of a
sudden now no one's thinking about Obama
gate you know it was seriously damage
for Biden Biden was he said some crazy
racist things you know if you ain't
black
you right you're not voting or if you're
not voting Biden was implicated in
unmasking Michael Flynn right and the
day his name got Lee
gets implicated in the whole Obama gig
thing then that story's gone and then
because he said you ain't black he's
gone it's just like you know now
everyone's just it's all about riot it's
all about you know racists everything
yeah it's it's really interesting that
let's go check it out I'm trying to
break it all down there's so much yeah
going up first the prisons alright right
the prisons so there's a video from I
did a segment on it this rider he's a
looter was caught he is he they were
they were looting some building right
his buddies everybody jump out and get
in the car and he was too slow so they
speed off he gets arrested so he's asked
why are you doing this and he goes man I
just wanted the money and he was like is
this anything to do with the you know
George Floyd protest and he goes I mean
a little bit but if I'm gonna be honest
I just wanted the money it's like there
it is yeah so let me ask you a question
all these prisons that released all
these prisoners for kovin yeah and then
had to really speak were attempted to
right is it possible I'm just I'm just I
don't I don't know because we haven't we
haven't I'll say it because this is what
I was what I was thinking that they were
losing the Democrats are in a corner
they they they are cleat they have no
they have got Biden sleepy Joe they're
like oh man what are we gonna do we got
to figure out some way to blame Trump
for something you know release all these
criminals all right now that no one has
these jobs we're gonna we're gonna shine
a huge spotlight on the next thing that
happens and put it up on all the press
yeah I mean if you think about it the
protesters are the overall majority are
peaceful yeah until the riot starts and
then everyone just goes nuts right well
what's starting the riots that's a thing
criminals know it's it's absolutely yes
they're definitely criminals yeah of
course but you know it's not that was
broad it's not the protesters though the
people that are walking peacefully
protesting aren't the ones that are they
they you know yeah it's a slippery slope
here fine line yeah you know it's like
they are angry rightly so right every
single video I've seen of rioters
starting things it's not the protesters
it's far
left activists and I'm not saying
anything about race yes it plays a huge
part in that but I'm seeing like an Tifa
starting these things it's like that's
not a protestors those are those aren't
the people that are angry about George
Floyd I know that's Andy and this is
crazy this is the like they're mem their
manifesto kind of going around mm-hmm
it's their membership what do you call
it's like how to form an edge of a group
okay you know Manuel and it specifically
says to pretend to be black lives matter
right because well because liberals
don't like you and so you see these
videos from actual black lives matter
activists and like there's one that's
going viral where it's two white women
tagging BLM I saw that and there's a
black woman who she's like what are you
doing we're gonna get blamed for this
yeah and they're like don't worry about
it don't worry about it I saw that bit
where there's the video where the black
woman has the brick and she walks it
with a car and she goes why did you just
give a bunch of young black men a brick
are you crazy Jeff sorry I'm sorry and
she gives her the brick she's got the
camera on the car and it's full of white
kids
yeah but white it looks like what are
you doing right there so exciting this
stuff so look what's hanging the washer
wrong we got to walk through that that
list you had in the beginning I know
there's so much they let the prisoners
out right then they say shut your
business down yeah this is you know what
a million people lose their jobs
well here's I have the sang that tell
people how many coincidences until
you've won the lottery yeah was it five
or six let's talk about the millions
right Powerball it's like six numbers I
think right mm-hmm
yeah six numbers on the squat one
through seventy like what are the number
is seventy to ninety nine or something
never have no idea the chance you
wouldn't water its astronomical you know
sometimes people in the lottery the
point I'm making with that is how many
coincidences until you're like come on
man did we just win the lottery so look
that this is this is where it makes me
question things but of course I don't
make decisions or or I don't act upon
assumptions almost have hard evidence
yeah I don't know some chance I need
hard evidence so what I see is the
Democrats tell everyone I want to shut
their businesses down they do you know
so what happens
perishable goods gone within you know
within a few weeks
all those goods are gone and any
restaurant that wants to reopen its got
to reinvest 20 grand
I know food you don't have it food
spoiled right but it's okay it's okay
because a lot of the hard goods stores
can reopen and all their hard goods are
just right there waiting for you and
then oh the same people who told all of
us to stay home encouraged everyone to
come out and grieve and what happened
someone put bricks all over these cities
yeah and then people smash all those
stores with hard goods and the hard
goods get stolen hmm you know a man how
many coincident ill you've won the
lottery I gotta say man I gotta say
you're seeing I have covered these
protests for a decade yeah I have never
seen stacks of bricks lined up outside
of all of these places neither by never
I've been there with you yeah I've never
seen it like we were we were at a place
where they like burned a car yeah they
were throwing bottles and threw me a
bottle at me no no bricks yeah but what
you walk up to it to a courthouse and
there's a big ol stack of bricks and the
protesters are calling it out even
people who protest who know this yeah
cuz they're not rioters they're
protesters and there's that one video I
love where the guys like this is a setup
yeah it's like you got to do better this
is a setup mm-hmm these these people
know what they're seeing there was one
where woman is like why are these bricks
dropped right in front of this building
what is this yeah yeah somebody is
organizing and I think it's I think it's
an Tifa I think so too but would you
guys look what you got to understand
about anti-fog what they're planning on
going going after them as my
understanding is individual domestic
terror charges mm-hmm so far left
extremism now all of these pundits I see
are popping up being electro food dumb
thing anti-flu tourists and I'm like I
was talking to this guy now and I said
you know what would you call it and he's
like snot terror and I'm like okay hold
on let me ask you something when they
sent me a picture of my of my fan 20
posted a picture online of me and my me
and another photo had my mom on it and
then lied about means crazy ways and
then some people in when I was in
Berkeley threatened me and tried to
fight me and some dude intervene to stop
them when they sent me emails with my
address on it
when it sent me death threats what do
you call him is that we look they're
politically motivated I pulled up the
definition okay here's the the
definition of terrorism yes the use of
violence and threats to intimidate
coerce especially for political purposes
that's number one number two the state
of fear and submission produced by
terrorism and three a terroristic method
of governing or resisting of government
this is that's exactly what these people
are doing yep and what people what we
are seeing with an tyfa mm-hmm is the
intelligent strategic evolution of
insurgency you know where they know if
they create a group and call it like you
know the fighting mongooses then the
police are gonna be alike which one of
you is part of the fighting mongooses
and who's the leader and where's the
money come from so what they do is they
pretend to not exist it even says in the
manual that if you form a group don't
give it a name and and don't allow
Outsiders in it's a tight-knit group of
people there you have a vetting process
everyone's background checked and
someone has to vet for each person so
what they're doing is specifically
looking at the laws and how terrorism is
being enforced and then navigating
between them mmm to engage in terrorism
now I'll admit it is broad blunt
low-level terror and so the problem for
us when the far right whatever you want
to call them I don't think far right
makes sense I mean I guess culturally
engage in terror it is sharp it is it is
a rifle it is unloading on tons of
people these things are rare but when
they happen shocks the minds of
everybody mm-hmm and that's damaging to
their own cause because it makes
everyone hate them what anti foot does
is is low level enough where the press
won't pick it up is it news to the
average American that outside of Mike
Serna vich is event an tyfa strangle the
guy it's not the New York Post picked it
up because it was a local you know crime
event yeah I think I got arrested but
regular Americans never heard that
happened so antiva engages in these
low-level efforts to shock and scare
people and its death by a thousand cuts
yeah that's why it's more effective so
they don't they say we're just antiphon
so loose organization well who bought
you your clothes yeah who bought you the
flag and who's bailing you out of prison
Justin Timberlake yeah and Christie
Tigan and Steve Steve Carell was it
Steve Carell Steve Carell other
celebrities Joe Biden staffers so this
is interesting now if trump's gonna
charge them as terrorists and joe biden
is bailing them out his campaign is yeah
yeah
all his campaign staff I'd be very very
careful so so back to that list we're
talking about Democrats it wasn't only
Democrats to release prisoners they it
released all over the place okay
Democrats are the one who want to remain
locked down though yeah even though we
had data coming out seen the lockdown
wasn't working Republican states they'd
open Texas was the last to close first
one of the first to open and then after
your business is completely destroyed
and they're encouraging these same
people to come out you can still argue
it must be just stupid people all these
stupid Democrats knows what they're
doing they're there they're encouraging
CNN said the riding was just the
language of the unheard desperately
begging the riders not to bash a bottle
over their head like they did that those
those journalists I think was in
Louisville yeah then finally to top it
all off your business is now gone the
people the people that told you have to
go out and courage the protesters who
which morphed into riding and they kept
encouraging and defending it you know
saying oh but it's the police was at
fault and then finally when you're like
could it get any worse Joe Biden's staff
steps up and says by the way we're gonna
make sure we bail out those people that
destroyed your city can you imagine
living in a place like that
oh no gosh yikes man I'll tell you what
else the United States no longer has a
Second Amendment argument that's a good
point our debate it's it's night it's
over it's finished yeah do the others
and there's videos coming up all over
place people defending their businesses
and the people are just going around
there is nasai they're standing there
with with rifles and no one's touching
them there's no there's there there's no
more gun control debate because all
these when kovat happened all these
liberals showed up yeah and we're like
trying to buy guns and he was like the
you know the store owners are lying he's
gonna take a couple extra days you gotta
felt these forms and they're all shocked
yes now where are we man you about the
you hear about the bar owner in Omaha no
so a bar owner and his dad these these
riders were smashing everything up and
so the dad confronts this group and the
group shoves him down so then the son
shows that he's got a weapon so then two
guys jump him he pulls the weapon or
they charge at him so he pulls up and he
fires what he says were two warning
shots and then I guess they fled but
then another guy knocked him down and
jumped on his back I guess and then he
fired over his
shoulder shooting the dude in the neck
okay now in Omaha they're demanding he'd
be charged with murder yep
what yep and the prosecutor said no he
said based on reviewing the footage it
was self-defense oh there was footage of
it yeah
hey lucky he didn't start the fight you
know his dad did his dad got knocked
down he showed me was he was armed you
know and then the he got attacked he
defended himself yeah I think they'll be
more rights from that but we're seeing
this kind of stuff man
I've got dude I'm gonna be I can't I
don't wanna really reveal any identities
but let me just tell you a person I know
lifelong Democrat okay like hates the
Republicans yeah said to me the only way
that this comes is resolved is if Donald
Trump wins re-election and the
Republicans control every you know every
branch a lifelong Democrat told me that
and I'm laughing how long do you know
this person very long no very long yep
and friends of mine are man are they
getting it's it's not a red pill browser
it's a it's a gigantic red suppository
because it's one thing oh my god listen
everybody thank you thank you if you're
somebody who's like reading the Internet
you know you get read pilled when you're
lying oh that's crazy I didn't know
about that
how these people are waking up one day
seeing you see that guy who was like
woohoo riots and then they came to his
house he was like oh no riots yeah the
other dude was like yeah burn it down is
that the same yeah yeah sure of the
building so yeah burn it all down and
then it's like wait a minute don't come
to my town and burn it down below go
burn your own houses like it's what it's
the low-income housing yeah and he's
like burn it down and then he posts
about how he's like I'm gonna go join
the protests and stuff yeah then they
come to his house and he's just freaking
out and he literally said don't come to
my community we care about our stuff go
to downtown LA that's where the that's
where the poor people are so he's
cheering when the poor people burn their
own stuff down that semester that is a
red suppository it's very clear that it
it's a huge class issue you know and
that's that's a big part that people
seem to not want to talk about you know
the whole it's it's a class the
lower-class are really are a target here
you know it used to be that we
understood this Occupy Wall Street was
when people were talking about class
issues yeah and then they introduced an
identity politics so like no no it's a
race issue racism controls everything
now I'm not saying there isn't racism
that exists cuz absolutely it's out
there but it is a huge class issue and
that's what we were talking about before
about living in cities we we have to pay
others for all of our services and
that's part of you know that it's like
working for yourself or working for
someone else forever but now you're
living for someone else and working for
someone else
so all every aspect of your life you you
basically have someone else you have to
answer to and that's the problem
you know people Mike Stern a [ __ ]
tweeted this if you're not familiar he's
like a very prominent Trump supporter I
don't know what you call him now
conservative but he said his prediction
is that Trump wins a narrow victory unka
Republicans lose the Senate hmm I don't
know he said about the house and I'm
wondering man could that be like after
all this people would vote Democrat huh
I guess maybe some people have messaged
me and they said I'm wrong the race is
really close and I have to stop
pretending like you know Trump's gonna
take it and I'm like but I listen man I
grew up in Chicago
you grew up in Chicago yeah then you and
you moved out the people like well I
lived in the city until I was three and
then I moved to the suburbs so I
wouldn't say I lived in well I mean but
Chicagoland area that's what yeah yeah
like everyone there is a Democrat for
the most part yeah not my family that
lives there no no once you get in the
suburbs you can find little Republican
pockets yeah but I grew up in the city
everyone's a Democrat and people I know
now there are like diehard Trump and I'm
like I can't see it I can't maybe
there's other areas the suburbs change
to Republican to Democrat I don't know I
guess if these protesters show up with
the suburbs then it'll be it'll be a
wake-up call for a lot of people yeah
but to see a lot of these upper-middle
class and like you know snooty elites
shocked that the purge actually included
them too you know so they thought they
were like it's fun to watch on TV
reminds me of the movie the hunt you
know they're rich elitist Sarah lie
we're gonna go hunt these people and
it's like don't get it thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you